Haaaa chui pas révéillé
Je suis pas réveillé c'est terrible.. C'est terrible.
Bah voilà excellent début de vidéo, Bonjour !
Aujourd'hui on est sur "Sort the Court !"
Ça fait 10 minutes que je réfléchis à comment ça se dit pu**in
Et qu'est ce que c'est que "Sort the Court" ?
C'est un simulateur de Roi...
...yaume !
Et de Roi tout court..
Voici donc l'interface du jeu, on a de l'argent, on a un peuple et on a un indice de satisfaction.
Là je balance comme ça mais j'en sais rien en vrai
Mon Seigneur je vais t'aider à diriger ton Royaume. Mais tu vas devoir faire des choix, tu répondras juste par oui ou non ok ?
OK
Notre ville est très petite actuellement, mais elle a carrément le potentiel de grossir.
Actuellement la seule chose dont tu dois te soucier est de rendre les citoyens heureux.
Et de faire grossir ta population !
Fait de ton mieux 'Sir'
Ok my 'Lady'
Elle s'en va et c'est parti. Premier habitant qui finalement est..
... un amas de déchets..
Et est ce que tu pourrais dire aux gens d'arrêter de m'appeler 'une slimball' ?
Je me sens mal à cause de ça..
Non.. NON
T'as la gueule d'une slimball
Hahaha
Le pire Roi du monde
Awww man - Il est dégouté
Allez ça dégage...
Héé comment ça vaaaheaaa... ?
Tu as volé l'oiseau de Bastion ?
Je dis "non" à ta demande.
Non non non on va arrêter les conneries, on va arrêter les conneries
Et j'ai une proposition de Business pour toi et ta petite ville t'es intéressé ?
OK C'est quoi ?
Aha, je t'apporterais bientôt des détails...
OK
Maman dit que j'ai besoin de votre permission pour partir à l'aventure
Aller va mon enfant va, amuse toi !
Ouais j'suis super excité d'explorer
J'suis sûr il va se faire buter la mère elle va se plaindre et j'aurais -20 d'indice de satisfaction !
C'est toujours comme ça ! Et après y'a la démocratie qui arrive, je suis détrôné !
Bon il me faut une couronne. Bon j'ai ça. Ça va être ma couronne. Voilà ma couronne
Elle est parfaite.
Et attend je suis roi et j'ai pas de couronne
C'est quoi ces conneries... Autant être premier ministre dans ce cas hein
Suivant
Il y a un enfant très puant qui court dans les rues. Est ce qu'on doit la forcer à avoir un bain ?
Heuu elle est peut être allergique au savon hein.. Et ça va me retomber dessus..
Si ça me retombe dessus qu'est ce qui se passe ? C'est la démocratie qui vient ?
Bon vas-y ok on le tente, vas-y vas-y elle pue et tout.
-1, pourquoi ? Ah... parce qu'elle n'est pas contente qu'on doive la laver
Mais les autres sont contents, ils se tapaient l'odeur!
Je devrais avoir +10 d'indice de satisfaction !
J'me suis fait niquer.
Premier jour terminé : population +0
Les gens sont tristes, la ville se rétrécit.
Ouais... Mais j'ai encore ma couronne mon pote !
Ok, deuxième jour !
Donc ce mec a totalement la gueule d'un voleur niveau 100 dans WoW
qui te stun pendant 20 minutes et qui t'encule.
Et il dit que les gardes lui ont confisqué de l'or...
qu'il avait, euh.. "trouvé"..
et qu'il aimerait récupérer.
Va te faire enculer.
Voici comment gagner 25 pièces d'or.
Ça marche pas dans Wow, hein.
Si tu dis "va te faire enculer", nan.
Le mec va juste te duel et t'humilier.
Oh le coffre animé de l'Enutrof, dans Dofus !
Remember, les souvenirs, drop gelée, gel anneau, tout ça.
J'ai accidentellement mangé quelques personnes devant le bâtiment...
Est-ce qu'en retour je peux juste te payer avec de l'or ?
Tu crois que tu vas m'acheter comme ça ?
Merci gamin ;)
Oh, Merlin !
Je passais par là, et je me suis dit que tu aimerais un petit peu de magie.
Tu veux essayer ?
Bon vas-y j'essaye.
Allez, qui ne tente rien..
*musique triste*
*La déception*
Messieurs dames, c'est le début.. de la démocratie.
Ah mes excuses, je suppose que le sort s'est transformé en maléfice !
C'est pas grave gamin, tout le monde a le droit à l'erreur; hein ;)
Faites pendre cet homme !
Fin du jour 2. Population -15
Taux de satisfaction -14
Heu bah oui en même temps si il n'y avait pas eu un putain de maléfice là !
As-tu déjà vu un coffre au trésor faire un salto arrière ?
Nan.
Ok bah ça ne changera pas.. XD
*Gros blanc*
Faite pendre cet homme
Aaahh le mec et son business !
Une offre pour vous mon ami.
J’achèterai un convoi de luxe pour vous à très bon prix
Ho t'façon on est riche... Vas-y ok vas-y au pire c'est une affaire de merde.
Pourquoi -15 de satisfaction?
Pourquoi?
Mais moi j'voulais pas gagner encore plus de tune ! J'voulais en perdre et au contraire gagner de la satisfaction et tout !
Au final je vais finir très riche, mais très seul !
*Blanc*
Comme actuellement
Day 3 complété.
C'était le moins pire
de tous.
Pourquoi les gens se cassent encore ?
J'en ai marre.
Il faut que je fasse une action de malade la demain.
Allez vas-y.
Oh putain, encore de la magie ?
Maintenant les esprits sont apaises mais peut-etre devrions-nous leur offrir un peu d'or.
T'as pas l'impression de me prendre pour un con toi ?
Et ça permettra d'éviter qu'ils nous hantent à l'avenir !
Ok, vas-y. Ben d'toute façon je suis riche, vas-y c'est parti.
200 !!!
J'vais être très seul et très pauvre maintenant :')
Allez, ok, vas-y donne-leur là, qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise.
alors voilà ouais-ouais-ouais
Je ferai une cérémonie et j'offrirai ça au monde des esprits.
Peut-être que les esprits en retour ils vont amener des gens dans le village ?
Voilà, théorie de merde c'est gratuit
Hey ! Tu veux jouer à pile ou face avec moi ?
Face j'te donne un peu d'or, pile je prends l'âme de quelques personnes
Nan nan nan, dégage, aurevoir.
Ça dégage.
Est-ce qu'a un moment les gents font l'amour dans cette ville ? Est-ce qu'ils baisent ?
Est-ce qu'ils copulent ? Parce que là je vois qu'on est a 67 depuis une heure et ça bouge pas.
Putain !
Jour 4 completé : Population +0
Huit personnes qui se barrent, encore.
mais vous attend... pourquoi ?
Là y'a un négatif si ce n'est que les gens sont un peu plus contents
Pourquoi vous êtes huit à vous barrer ?
Je suis le pire roi du monde.
Salut mon ami, veux-tu regarder dans mon cristal magique de vampire ?
Allez vas-y de tte façon je suis désespéré mon gars...
Je vois la mort et la misère...
Ouais, mais tu vois pas la pauvreté !! $$$$$$$
Vive la thune ! La thune !
Putain, mais non mais les gens,
mais faites l'amour mec !
Eh, j'étais en train de me demander si j'allais pas ouvrir une boutique de soupe ?
Vous pensez que c'est une bonne idée? J'aurais besoin d'argent.
Vas-y tiens, d'te facon je suis plus à ça près mais tout va bien. Mets toi bien cousine.
+10 gens!!!
Mais attend elle fait des soupes ça attire les gens quoi !
Ah oui ca c'est la bouffe de grand-mère ca, j'avoue.
Oh putain lui il m'a bien douillé.
"Je passais par là et je me disais que vous aimeriez bien un peu de magie,
Tout peut arriver, vous voulez essayer ?"
Vas-y mec, attend je me suis fait niquer deux fois, la troisième...
Voilà !!! Oui !
Oh putain ! C'est la remontée d'un roi !
Allez, je remets cette couronne au peuple parce que je suis vraiment un roi clément.
Vous pendrez cet homme qui a mis la couronne sur sa tête.
"Les ouvriers aimeraient construire plus de maisons en ville.
Ils veulent de l'argent avec lequel ils pourront construire plus vite"
Mais donne leur avec grand plaisir !
Allez eh, la mec...
et du coup attends
Fin de la journée, y'a des gens qui vont venir du coup ?
Mais pourquoi, parce que j'avais happyness -5 ?
Mais tout à l'heure  j'avais happyness +2 et y'a huit mecs qui sont quand même partis !
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour que les gens restent?
Mais vous vous êtes pris pour qui là ?!
Je les écraserai tous ces vulgaires cafards !
"On a capturé des prisonniers sur le champ de bataille,
Est-ce qu'on devrait les apporter ici et les mettre au travail ?"
Oui mec, mais oui, mais oui,
mais quelle bonne idée, déjà parce que ça fait huit mecs en plus dans ma petite ville de merde !
Et ensuite parce qu'on va les exploiter mon gars !
On connait pas le SMIC nous, on connait pas !
"Oh mon cher j'ai eu la terrible nouvelle dans le journal aujourd'hui,
tu penses que tout ira bien ?"
Mais oooouuuuiiii, je sais pas de quoi tu parles, mais biensûr, biensûr je suis un très bon roi.
Alors là si y'a des gens qui se ....
MAIS POURQUOI VOUS VOUS BARREEEEEEEZI!!!???
MAIS QU'EST-CE QU'ILS VEULENT !?
J'en ai marre je suis un, mauvais roi.
Revoilà, le le l'homme d'affaires
"Donne-moi deux cents pièces d'or et je t'ammène un truc.."
Vas-y ok, vas-y, je suis un vicos je dis oui à tout.
Ah bah voilà ! Les gens ils sont contents! C'est très bien.
J'ai plus de tune mais c'est pas grave c'est très bien.
Alors là les gens ils partent pas... regarde mec la tune que j'ai dépensé,
Ah c'est ça, plus je dépense de tune, plus les gens ils viennent.
Ok bravo, bravo hein ! Bravo !
Après ça parle des youtubers qui pensent qu'à l'argent.
Nan mais...
"Est-ce que tu veux que je vole de l'argent aux riches et que je te le donne ?
Bon pas qu'aux riches en fait je veux voler à tout le monde.
Mec tu m'as pris pour le, le roi Dagobert là ?
Je sais pas pourquoi j'ai dit Dagobert !
*musique : Le bon roi Dagobert,
Avait sa culotte à l'envers,*
Est-ce que ce caleçon avec des bouches hideuses,
Est à l'envers ?
Non !
*Le grand Saint Eloi lui dit :
"O mon Roi, Votre majesté
Est mal culottée"*
Non, ah bah ça c'est pas moi !
Non
Moi il me dit ça qu'est ce que je dis ?
Pendez cet homme s'il vous plaît !
Les villageois se plaignent du bordel qu'il y a dans les rues,
Est ce qu'on devrait demander aux travailleurs
de la nettoyer ?
Allez vas-y... Et me dit pas -100,
-50 !!!
Pffff ça va, ça va, ça va, ça va, ça va.
Hey, quelqu'un est venu chez moi et a tout nettoyé !
Et tu vas me payer pour ça !
Non ! Euh, dégage !
Il y a une fête à laquelle j'aimerai aller ce soir,
Est-ce que je peux avoir le reste de ma journée, en off ?
Mais oui vas-y mets toi bien !
Mets toi bien, en plus tu ressembles à mon père quand il avait 25 ans,
Ça me fais plaisir.
putaiin on est à 185 personnes c'est incroyable !
quoi c'est quoi ça ?!
Des villageois menacent de partir tant qu'on ne le leur a pas donné un peu d'argent !
MAIS VOUS ÊTES MARRANT VOUS CROYEZ QUE MOI JE VAIS VOIR MANUEL VALLS ET FRANCOIS HOLLANDE
ET JE LEURS DEMANDE DE LA THUNE SINON JE PARS DE PARIS
Ils me rient au nez mon gars, ils me pètent au cul !
NAN !
Vas-y qu'ils dégagent
Ils étaient 6 mon gars, 6 pecnot la
Ils me mettent dans des états pas possible
J'ai faim est-ce que je peux manger des gens ?
J'ai de l'argent donc je peux te payer contre leurs vies
Toi ... toi aussi tu m'as pris pour Dagobert
ok ouais !
OUIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIII
+100 mon gars !!
au fil du temps le roi Dago ...
C'EST PAS DAGOBERT !
Le roi blasé tomba dans une profonde dépression
Il répondait de manière aléatoire aux demandent des habitants tout en ayant rien à foutre
Vous le voyez maintenant entrain de faire cette voix-off complètement nulle.
Eh bien voilà c'est la fin de notre règne,
Place maintenant à la démocratie.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu, si vous avez aimé le jeu vous pouvez le télécharger il est gratuit
Par contre c'est que en Anglais hein !
Bon voilà
Après ces 2 dernières années c'était un peu moi votre prof d'anglais donc je pense que vous avez un petit niveau
I believe in you !
Aller à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo ! Merci d'avoir regardé portez vous bien
Tchao Tout le monde ! PEACE !
*Générique de fin*